I know the smokey was probably not good
for my health
most people who smoke in America know
this smoking is probably not good for
their health do we need the federal
government the jealous this legislations
on the floor because people are killing
themselves smoking these evil cigarettes
and the distinguished gentlemen the
majority of the minority leader is going
to be amongst the next to die
smoke belly smoke twice as refresh
in New York City a single pack of
cigarettes will set you back $12
you can't smoke them in your local bar
or after a meal and your favorite
restaurant if Mayor Mike Bloomberg cuts
his way he usually does you soon won't
be able to light up in parks or on
beaches either and if the federal
government gets its way you soon might
not be able to legally purchase menthol
cigarettes anywhere in the past decade
the government has stepped up its
campaign against cigarette smoking and
the companies that produce them you
might have noticed that your light
cigarettes are no longer light but gold
or blue can't say medium light or ultra
light anymore lest one get the
impression that this particular brand
might give you an ultra light form of
cancer recently the FDA banned flavored
cigarettes stopping the scourge of
banana and spice smokes that no one had
ever heard of prior to the ban these
candy flavored cigarettes supposedly
hooked kids when they're young masking
as one critic says the taste of the
poison but dr. Michael Siegel an
anti-smoking activist and professor at
Boston University's School of Public
Health says that arguments claiming
flavored cigarettes are a gateway to
smoking are demonstrably false the ban
on so-called candy cigarettes was
symbolic and had no effect on teen
smoking rights in an effort to placate
the American tobacco industry and get
the bill passed menthol cigarettes were
exempted from the legislation because a
higher proportion of menthol smokers are
African American this was interpreted by
some as racist former Secretary of
Health Education and Welfare Joseph
Califano claimed the exemption was
clearly putting black children in the
back of the bus and the Congressional
Black Caucus demanded the menthol issue
be revisited soon but Califano can sleep
easy because now the FDA has revisited
the issue with a vengeance I'm tempting
to ban the sale and production of
Salem's and Newports again arguing that
they are a gateway cigarette and if
there are ill health effects unique to
menthols because that is the important
first step we must take in order to get
to the point where products like menthol
that we believe may injure the health of
minorities and others will no longer be
available but our menthol cigarettes
worse for you than non flavored
cigarettes are they harder to quit as
its opponent suggests despite the claims
by anti tobacco zealots there's no
evidence to suggest that a marlboro
menthol is more harmful than a Marlboro
light nor any that suggests they're more
difficult to quit despite the constant
in bouquet
of the kids a ban on menthol makes no
sense I'll smoke to that as professor
Siegel points out all cigarettes contain
flavor additives to entice people to
their brand all camels for instance
contain brown sugar high fructose corn
syrup cocoa and licorice after a ban on
phantom banana cigarettes and now
menthols what will prevent government
regulators from banning all cigarettes
well that's the point as we're looking
as I am to admit it
in this instance John Bainer is right
they're not a smoker in America it
doesn't understand that smoking is it
good for you further government
intervention to prevent smokers from
having a choice are merely steps on the
road to the complete abolition of
tobacco products and therefore the
creation of an enormous black market for
Reason TV I'm Michael Moynihan